We have already seen
an example in which we
have two events
that are independent
but become dependent
in a conditional model.
So that [independence] and
conditional independence
is not the same.
We will now see another example
in which a similar situation is
obtained.
The example is as follows.
We have two possible
coins, coin A and coin B.
This is the model
of the world given
that coin A has been chosen.
So this is a
conditional model given
that we have in
our hands coin A.
In this conditional model, the
probability of heads is 0.9.
And, moreover, the
probability of heads
is 0.9 in the second
toss no matter
what happened in the first
toss and so on as we continue.
So given a particular
coin, we assume
that we have independent tosses.
This is another way
of saying that we're
assuming conditional
independence.
Within this conditional model,
coin flips are independent.
And the same
assumption is made in
the other possible
conditional universe.
This is a universe in which
we're dealing with coin B.
Once more, we
have, conditionally
independent tosses.
And this time, the probability
of heads at each toss is 0.1.
Suppose now that we choose
one of the two coins.
Each coin is chosen with
the same probability, 0.5.
So we're equally likely
to obtain this coin--
and then start flipping
it over and over--
or that coin-- and start
flipping it over and over.
The question we
will try to answer
is whether the coin
tosses are independent.
And by this, we
mean a question that
refers to the overall model.
In this general model, are
the different coin tosses
independent?
Where you do not know ahead of
time which coin is going to be.
We can approach this
question by trying
to compare conditional and
unconditional probabilities.
That's what
independence is about.
Independence is about certain
conditional probabilities
being the same as the
unconditional probabilities.
So this here, this
comparison here
is essentially the question
of whether the 11th coin
toss is dependent or
independent from what
happened in the
first 10 coin tosses.
Let us calculate
these probabilities.
For this one, we use the
total probability theorem.
There's a certain probability
that we have coin A,
and then we have the probability
of heads in the 11th toss given
that it was coin A. There's
also a certain probablility
that it's coin B and then
a conditional probability
that we obtain heads
given that it was coin B.
We use the numbers that
are given in this example.
We have 0.5 probability of
obtaining a particular coin,
0.9 probability of heads
for coin A, 0.5 probability
that it's coin B, and
0.1 probability of heads
if it is indeed coin B.
We do the arithmetic,
and we find
that the answer is 0.5,
which makes perfect sense.
We have coins with
different biases,
but the average bias is 0.5.
If we do not know which
coin it's going to be,
the average bias
is going to be 0.5.
So the probability of heads
in any particular toss
is 0.5 if we do not
know which coin it is.
Suppose now that
someone told you
that the first 10
tosses were heads.
Will this affect your
beliefs about what's
going to happen
in the 11th toss?
We can calculate
this quantity using
the definition of
conditional probabilities,
or the Bayes' rule, but let
us instead think intuitively.
If it is coin B, the
events of 10 heads in a row
is extremely unlikely.
So if I see 10
heads in a row, then
I should conclude that there
is almost certainty that I'm
dealing with coin A.
So the information
that I'm given
tells me that I'm extremely
likely to be dealing with coin
A. So we might as well condition
on this equivalent information
that it is coin A
that I'm dealing with.
But if it is coin A, then
the probability of heads
is going to be equal to 0.9.
So the conditional
probability is
quite different from the
unconditional probability.
And therefore, information
on the first 10 tosses
affects my beliefs
about what's going
to happen in the [11th] toss.
And therefore, we do
not have independence
between the different tosses.